hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and if you were reading the title
and says reuploaded to all the people
that have previously watched the video
you can click off now it's the same
thing that I had this morning but to all
the people that were new I basically had
the video up but then you can see that I
got called out in the comments but the
person that has every right to be a
little bit angry I made the video about
6 and a half minutes long for videos I
could have easily taken me 30 seconds to
a minute and a half to explain how to
get the most you know steel in the game
and stuff like that so anyway if you've
already seen the videos and click off
I'll see you guys in the next one and
whenever I decide to post that but if
you're new welcome to this video
basically we're going to show you how to
get probably the most amount of steel
you can you know because there is no
glitches or anything now yet and I don't
plan on finding or doing these glitches
anyway if they were out but the two
options that you have or you can either
buy the champion status which does cost
real money for you to get more XP and
more steel per game than normal or you
can go over to multiplayer go over to
the orders and then scroll down here to
daily orders contract orders and event
order as you can see the event order is
almost completed which will give us 500
steel and then 2 scavenger crates all
these contracts will give you all the
contract orders will give you 100 steel
and all the daily orders will give you
300 every single time just to recap the
daily orders give you 300 steel the
contract orders give you 100 in the
event order if they have one will give
you 500 the problem is that we have to
work for this so it's really how to get
the most steel just kind of grind these
out find the ones that are super simple
like these ones basically this all I had
to do is play elimination could knock
that out in five minutes
find the easiest ones for you to do and
then slowly get up to the harder ones
then you can rack in it a bunch of Steel
per day my end up having over 2000 after
playing for a while so anyway guys it's
going to be a really quick video super
short like I said this was a real blow
the person was watching this sorry I
made this 6 minutes but I changed it but
uh I'll see you guys in the next video
and uh